la première ministre la flambée des prix
de l'énergie est une inquiétude majeure
pour tous les Français comment
comment
sensible à la détresse de nos artisans
commerçant chef d'entreprise et
agriculteurs qui voient à leur activité
menacées
comment comment pouvons-nous tolérer le
fait que des Français renoncent à se
chauffer dignement cet hiver
comment comment pouvons-nous accepter
que nos collectivités territoriales ne
puissent plus assurer certains services
essentiels je pense d'ailleurs à nos
collectivités locales dans nos
territoires ruraux et de montagne qui
souffrent plus spécifiquement
certaines communes vont alors factures
multipliées par 5
face à cette situation les aides
actuelles mises en place ne suffisent
pas
les critères sont trop restrictifs
oubliant de trop nombreux Français
plus largement aujourd'hui
toutes vos réponses sont insuffisantes
nous devons réviser et je dis bien
réviser durablement le calcul du prix de
l'énergie qui est pénalise fortement
notre pays
alors madame la Première ministre
portez-nous des solutions
concrètes rapides et efficace les
Français nous regardent et comptent sur
vous pour agir fortement à leur service
je vous remercie